good mornin well it's probably later the
O's you on the east coast but I only got
up going a few hours ago because
yesterday I shot a bunch of stuff for
IMDB I'm gonna be covering Sundance form
like I covered san diego comic-con so we
shot a bunch of promos and stuff then i
shot new episodes of fat man on Batman I
did some writing yesterday was kind of a
PAC tech today nothing to do except this
ready there she is my rock and my
salvation this little dog forces me to
get out of the house once a day and do
this dopey walk and you would imagine
that every time we went on this walk
something astounding was going to happen
the energy we're on our way home this is
her going home look how happy she is and
she knows when she gets something
there's [ __ ] boredom city again so
but still relentless joy oh my God we're
out it's another day even though it's
crappy day Lee that's crappy Los Angeles
weather today cigar yup you're fat [ __ ]
we'd be home if it weren't for your fat
ass so on the day off him I still got
the dog duty but I don't mind doing the
dog duty man it sounds [ __ ] filthy uh
I also received a cabin member of the
academy of motion picture arts and
sciences and they sent out you know
screeners Oscar screeners over here
that's part of the job nanas with you
like here's a bunch of movies you were
gonna go see and I usually buy the
tickets online anyway you know just cuz
support movies but uh they sent me
a rogue one screener that's right so I'm
gonna today kick back and blaze and then
I'm going to watch robe one and watch a
[ __ ] out of it probably rewind that
Darth Vader seen a couple thousand times
but then right after that I'm gonna
watch me some star wars as i thought
when i went to see wrote one at the
premiere I was like wouldn't be amazing
to go right from this movie into Star
Wars I said boy I can't wait till it's
on home video that I'll be able to do it
I could do it today so I canceled
everything I'm supposed to be doing got
ready purify myself I'm with the force
and the force is gonna be all over my
face neck and chest all day long
meanwhile let's check in with shaky
just she's relentless she just don't
stop hey hey hey enjoy the walk hurry up
you fat piece of [ __ ] it's telling me my
connection is weak it's just like
Facebook live is just like the internet
I get on in there like you're weak
shit's weak solid bill I'm like Bob all
right we're on our way back down the
hill subsistence traction going on this
house over here man who's ripping it to
shreds making all all new house yeah
I'll show you
it's cool dope-ass man's right next to
the south he's kind of the two nicest
situated houses I think in the
neighborhood cuz they look out all over
Los Angeles uh they've working on for a
while now just started taking everything
down get it ready hello how are you good
friendly neighborhood spider kid so what
else is going on in the world I don't
know christmas is coming and or you know
the holidays whatever you want to call
in Hanukkah Kwanzaa they're all coming
hard this is the time to be with loved
ones and reflect on the year that was
and build hope for the year that's to
come so hopefully everyone gets to do
that this week I know a lot of people
have to work like right up to the
holidays and betcha there's some poor
sons of [ __ ] were [ __ ] going to be
working holiday itself just make sure
you take a little time to be with your
family when I was a kid you know I liked
my family an awful lot oh [ __ ] but you
know at a certain point I just wanted to
grow the [ __ ] up and start my life and
stuff and here's a dopey story my father
when when BMX bikes became a big thing
and that was like 19 let's say 80 81 or
something like that late 70s early 80s
suddenly having a BMX bike was that's
the only thing that made you a love
child not a love child but a loved'
child proof that your parents love you
so I did not have a BMX bike and I kept
talking about wanting one but we were
broke broke as a joke my old man worked
for the post office and they didn't pay
insanely well so one day my old man
works at nights right
and then while I'm at school during the
day he's he's like sleeping or wakes up
starts his day watches TV and sure he
had this project going in the garage for
about a month not be like what's dad
doing out there cuz he was not like a
handyman guy and my mom was like you'll
see you'll see and you know I didn't
know what it was found out what it was
can't remember when it when we did it
but it was around Christmas and my
father had taken like my old piece of
[ __ ] bike a green has bike could hand me
down bike and I don't know spent like 50
bucks in 1980-81 to trick it out to hold
on now we're just here for a second to
trick that [ __ ] up and turn it into a
homemade BMX bike and I remember being
like oh my god I can't [ __ ] ride this
is he serious but I was raised a pretty
black kid so I was just like this rocks
dad I probably did say rocks buzzing Wow
but inside I was dying son died and this
bike was ugly a [ __ ] and and you like it
had no you know how BMX bike has like
the [ __ ] bar goes across you know now
kids I guess called mountain bikes of
[ __ ] but has that bar that goes across
the handlebars so my bike didn't have
that bar my father built the bar with
like a [ __ ] little piece of plastic
or aluminum piping with some wire that
like kind of secured it to the
handlebars ha thetic I mean it was like
you know what I'd rather drive the old
bike around he put a plate on it like so
yellow plate had like 0 1 on it and
stuff like that um and damned if I
didn't if I didn't hate that bike when I
got it but I'll be lying you know
where's is going I'd be lying if I
didn't tell you that every Christmas I
think of that bike and I you know I got
some a little bit of loot we're not
[ __ ] super rich but I definitely got
a little bit aloof from being in the
entertainment business all this time I
would trade all of that
for that bike again I'm not saying
that's my rosebud but like I didn't
appreciate it when I got it it was a
[ __ ] kid I just wanted new now I
understand the beauty of like something
homemade my old man toiling and the
garage he was not a handyman by
stretching the imagination asked my mom
he was a handyman in as much as he got
handies and that was about it from my
mother but in any event that's that's
the stuff you think about when you're
middle-aged when you're 46 Christmases
past that you wish you'd reacted better
or it really it just comes down to being
with loved ones and stuff here let me
show you California me show you Los
Angeles ready first I'll show you the
dog
now I'll show you the view and a
gorgeous
that's the view from up here gonna tell
you what man I'm out and show you her
actual place but that's penny Marshall's
we don't that's that's where penny
marshall lives over there laverne phone
varnish early um who I used to watch
growing up as a kid every Tuesday night
with my mother after [ __ ] happy days
and [ __ ] like that never knowing years
later I'd be your neighbor you can
listen to an episode of SModcast we did
a couple years back a couple of so she's
wonderful and any event that's her
[ __ ] view phenomenal there it is
folks holidays be with some loved ones
take that special time span yes but take
it and appreciate it goes by quick and
then people are dead and you never get
to do that [ __ ] again so as my words of
wisdom for the day that's my motivation
go hug a relative hug a cop yeah I said
it that's from flesh all right man check
in one last time Shecky check any words
of wisdom thoughts
check is like I was just being with
family if fat [ __ ] and thank God that he
don't try to eat me that'd be me alright
thanks for hanging out man quick walk
this is like a mile and a half every day
up and down a hill almost two miles and
you know no sugar got back on sheriff
for a minute there and gain weight so
now I'm more sugar it's been almost a
month ready to [ __ ] kill somebody but
weights falling off all right have a
good one folks no I'm not trying to leak